we saw in the body cam footage is both
horrifying seeing poor Paul Pelosi in
his 80s get hit with a hammer it's just
absolutely awful but it's also weird
standing there with a drink what was
that we can't even speculate as to what
that was and then the 9-1-1 call reveals
above all that the 911 operator should
be fired immediately has there ever been
a dumber 911 operator probably not we
can't have dumb 911 operators it really
matters
but above all and we hate to defend NBC
news but we just got to be honest the
body cam footage completely vindicates
reporting from NBC's Miguel and Maguire
back in November here's what he reported
sources familiar with what unfolded in
the Pelosi residence now revealing when
officers responded to the high priority
call they were seemingly unaware they'd
been called to the home of the speaker
of the house after a knock-in announce
the front door was opened by Mr Pelosi
the 82 year old did not immediately
declare an emergency or tried to leave
his home but instead began walking
several feet back into the foyer toward
the assailant and away from police why
Pelosi didn't try to flee or tell
responding officers he was in distress
is unclear we still don't know exactly
what unfolded between Mr Pelosi and the
suspect for the 30 minutes they were
alone inside that house before police
arrived
so that's kind of amazing I mean the guy
was just doing his job he clearly talked
to someone who saw the body cabin
footage now we can see the body cam
footage and we know he was basically
right that's what it showed
so news organizations don't typically
punish reporters for getting the story
right but NBC punished that guy they
suspended him then they deleted that
report from their website we asked NBC
Today why would they do that but they
did not respond of course we didn't know
the answer which is that body cam
footage whatever else it proves and once
again we're not exactly sure what it
approves
it definitely puts a crimp in their
preferred story which was that the
Pelosi household was invaded by Q Anon
activists or something or this was some
right-wing militia attack on the speaker
of the House's husband
that's not what it shows and that NBC
reporter was honest enough just to kind
of describe what it does show
and for his efforts of telling the truth
he was suspended shame on NBC News
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight